this is the Baltic Sea boats are moored
in the harbour near the upscale keel
Yacht Club Abhijit Banerjee of India is
familiar with the world of the well-off
he has a PhD from Harvard and teachers
today at the elite university MIT he was
born in Calcutta into a very different
life it just happened to be that after
my grandfather built his house that area
became a large slum and so it was so I
played with kids who had a very
different background I mean they were
live next door so I played with them and
I often felt like you know they had a
better life because they didn't have to
go to school the issue of poverty
continues to influence his life at the
Kiel Institute for the world economy
he's presenting his work after long
research projects in Asia and Africa
benarjee says there's no quick fix for
fighting poverty because economic
conditions are different in every region
we say it's poverty we'll throw money at
it we don't take it seriously as a
specific problem that has a specific
solution so I think that maybe in Asia
and Africa if you had the same problem
we were the same answer but often the
problems are different and therefore
have different answers the head of the
KL Institute for the world economy
values his work it allows policy makers
to base decisions on data gathered in
research in randomly selected
communities rather than simply relying
on gut feelings the serious attempt is
actually being made to figure out what
policy measures work and what don't in
medicine there are trials randomized
trials to quire which medications work
and this is an attempt to turn economic
policy making more into something that
resembles medicine in comparing rich
countries like Germany to poorer ones
Banerjee has repeatedly discovered that
people's needs really don't vary that
much
take for example the desire for
entertainment
he once observed a man in Morocco who
was clearly suffering from hunger but
spent what little money he had on a
television it was quite straight forward
he wasn't posturing or anything he said
you know sometimes the televisions more
important than food Banerjee also likes
to pepper his lectures with personal
anecdotes
he tells students that development aid
is a process limited to small steps
he says relief programs always need to
be monitored and updated
he's even advising the United Nations to
revise their list of Development Goals
benarjee says it's far too long what
they've come up with this idea 169
targets I think is self-defeating it's
just nobody's going to say if you go and
tell a country well you have to meet 169
goals they'll say we don't ever have the
time to measure them let alone achieve
them it's just I'm going to happen so I
think somewhere it has to the process
has to give and we have to go down to
like 30 or something or or I think this
whole thing is going to become pointless
his lectures are popular with the
students they're innovative in he gets
his point across you can tell he's
really interested in the subject he's
encouraged me to take a new approach to
these issues and be more precise about
the data and have a more objective
perspective
various philosophies are shared even
during the break and they told us to buy
things that were made in our country
Banerjee's time in germany has come to
an end but the discussion on how to
fight world poverty is long from over